Ich muss jetzt erst mal Teams fixen wieder, weil Teams SUCKT.
Das ist schon wieder hier im Chat los.
Hör mal kurz VM an.
Das nehme ich dann als Anzeige, ne als Testimonial heißt es ja.
Aber gibt es hier schon wieder Subs, was ist denn hier los?
Jetzt haben wir schon alles gemacht.
So viele Preischamps, warum sind so viele Preischamps auf, Alter, das übertreibt man
nicht Max.
Eigentlich Preischamp wäre heute gar nichts.
Subs gibt es und zwar, den habe ich übersehen, zeig mal her, hier sieht man es ja auch.
Der Clocks HD ist 16 Monate am Start, merci, Dankeschön, wie auch immer, 8 Monate Dankeschön
für den Sub.
Der Tains ist auch am Start, 19 Monate Alter, das geht ja schon fast auf 2 Jahre zu und
das Gametrain ist auch am Start, ich hoffe ich habe jetzt nichts übersehen.
Jemand von euch Gamestop Aktien, wobei gelaufen ist die Sache noch nicht.
Tja, und jetzt gleich mal am Anfang, die Musik ist komisch, die weiß nicht wie laut es sein
will.
Call me daddy, excellent name, Dankeschön für den Sub, leider mal an das ganze, so und
der Größe ist ok.
Ja, um das erste Mal zu zeigen, ihr habt es wahrscheinlich auf Twitter gelesen, ich mache
da vielleicht am Wochenende auch nochmal in einem Video was zu, der Preischamp ist jetzt
offiziell am Start, kann sich Twitter mal verpissen da unten, der Preischamp ist offiziell
am Start, habe ich vor einer Stunde gepostet, guck, jetzt kann man hier auch direkt auf
die Seite drauf, der Darkreader muss ausgemacht werden, der Darkreader muss hier ausgemacht
werden, so und jetzt ist das Ding erstmal live, es hat noch ein paar kleine Bugs, beispielsweise
dass das bei der Refresh Animation auf IOS ein bisschen wackelt, also ein bisschen rum
springt, aber das habe ich schon gefixt, ich wollte es jetzt nicht pushen, wenn gerade
so viele Leute das Ding ausprobieren, also ich kann jetzt Preischampen was das Zeug hält
und das gute ist, das aktualisiert sich mehr oder weniger selbst, das ist das geile daran,
du willst Timeout, ok easy, das aktualisiert sich mehr oder weniger selbst im Hintergrund,
ich habe das so eingestellt, dass der alle paar Stunden einen neuen Crawler pullt und
da kriege ich automatisch die neuesten Sachen drin, Alternate ist beispielsweise gefixt
seit heute, ja so sieht es aus, achja und übrigens hier, ich bin letztens an einer Exquisite
Impfgegner Kundgebung vorbeigelaufen, ich dachte eigentlich gar nicht, dass es sowas
gibt, dass das Internet sich das wieder ausgedacht hat, aber gibt es wirklich, war mir auch neu,
dass es da wirklich Leute gibt, aber kann ja jeder machen wie er will, die Polizei war
auch am Start, allerdings gehe ich mal von aus, die Polizei war eher zum Schutz der
Kundgebenden da, weniger zudem für die Leute die vorbeilaufen, weil man muss ja heute mit
allem rechnen, wenn man sich mit etwas kontroverser Meinung an die Öffentlichkeit wendet, so bescheuert
ich finde, dass die Leute sich nicht impfen lassen wollen, ich finde es aber gut, dass
sie sagen dürfen, 2 Wochen Bann, ja Instant, ne ne wir machen keinen Preischamp, der Preischamp
ist am Start, ich werde als Preischamp jetzt erstmal, was willst du am Preischamp jetzt
noch letztens großartig machen, ja 1000€ Spende, es kann keiner spenden, ähm gibt es
nicht, gibt da keine Möglichkeit zu spenden, gbait, gbait, gbait, der Preischamp ist nicht
open source, ne ne, aber der crawler ist open source, du hast den letzten Preis, ja der billigste
Preis, den kriegst du, wenn du es anklickst, die Leute finden das massif nice, habe ich
mitbekommen, wenn es permanent wackelt, das ist so der Casino Effekt, weiß auch nicht,
wofür ist die Suche da, du kannst zum Beispiel Filter nach Nvidia oder so, oder nach AMD
oder nach Xbox oder so, aber nach Hersteller kannst du noch nicht suchen, aber ihr seht
der Hersteller wird jetzt auch angezeigt, guckt hier, es ist Zotac dabei, Zotac, Asus, gut
die Dinger sind halt von AMD, da machst du nichts, also der Hersteller ist am Start,
Herwing, sieben Monate, danke schön für den Zap, das ist jetzt neu, ansonsten kann
man hier Filtern nach sieben Tagen, drei Monaten, einem Jahr, Stonks, man sieht auch, dass das
funktioniert, guck, das sind 1,2,3,4,5,6,7 Tage und das hier ist halt Maximum 1,2,3,4,5,6,7,8,9,10,
achja übrigens, wenn er was nicht findet, dann ist PepeHands angesagt, exquisite, ansonsten
gibt es da nicht wirklich viel Neues, weil was willst du da auch großartig Neues machen,
deswegen ich werde das jetzt auch erstmal so lassen, übrigens, ich hab mir überlegt,
nachdem wir letztens so geil gededost wurden, gut im Zweifelsfall würde ich jetzt einfach
Cloudflare direkt Attack Mode anmachen, aber ich hab versucht bei denen einen Server zu
kaufen, weil ich mir gedacht hab, ey, scheint ja einen ganz guten Eindruck zu machen, wow,
ich mag Seiten nicht, die sich selbst refreshen, Alter, so und dann hab ich mir gedacht, ich
kauf mir einfach dieses Ding hier, easy, angeklickt, gekauft, was der letzte verfügbare Preis
war, ja gut, der letzte verfügbare Preis ist jetzt aber halt nicht automatisch der billigste
Preis, ne, und fleißig sudo gepatcht, ich hab es nur ganz am Rand ehrlich gesagt verfolgt,
aber solang es kein Remote Code Execution ist, juckt es mich schnell, genau, wollte ich bestellen,
hab mich bestellt, alles wunderbar, und man muss dazu sagen, ich hab mich bei meinem Domain-Registrar,
bei Hetzner, bei 1&1, ja, ihr werdet lachen, ich hab sogar einen Server bei 1&1, bei total
vielen Dingern hab ich mich immer mit nicht ganz korrekten Benutzer registriert, aber
ich hab immer ordentlich bezahlt, weil ich dachte mir, das ist denen bestimmt egal, solang
man ordentlich bezahlt, und jetzt hab ich, ich hab mich bei denen registriert, alles
gut, Server bestellt, bezahlt, und auf einmal steht dann da, braucht 48 Stunden zum Freischalten,
da hab ich schon gedacht, äh, okay, das versteh ich jetzt nicht, wirklich unter Cloud, irgendwie
48 Stunden warten, bis freigeschaltet ist, aber wie kann man sich eigentlich in OBS
muten, so, ja, so, exquisite, genau, und dann 48 Stunden Zeit, und heute Morgen hab ich
ne Mail von denen gekriegt, ich soll meinen Ausweis einscannen und hinschicken, da hab
ich mir so gedacht, keck wait, das hab ich mir dann gedacht, und ich hab den Ausweis
nicht hingestickt, ich hab dann sollen den Account wieder zumachen, ich versteh's ja
irgendwie, wenn die schon viel gescampt wurden, wenn die schon viel gescampt wurden, dass
die da keinen Bock mehr drauf haben, ja, vielleicht registrier ich mich da nochmal, vielleicht
kann man ja, vielleicht kann man das ja mit denen besprechen, dass ich mich da registriere
mit echten Daten, aber die danach ändern kann, weil ich hab keinen Bock, dass ich das mal
irgendwie im Stream zeige, und dann irgendwie mich was auf mein Profil redirectet, und dann
dann meine echte Adresse, Name und Telefonnummer und alles drin steht, ja, also deswegen, also
ne, deswegen, ich will die Accounts, die ich im Stream verwende, absolut gar nicht, warum
kein Hetzner, warum kein Hetzner, Hetznern will das nicht, Hetznern ist das egal, Hetznern
bin ich mit Peter Wubbel oder so registriert, das juckt die überhaupt nicht, ne, einfach
russischen Fake Pass, ich glaub das fällt auf, sobald sich das den Menschen anguckt,
Hetznern will Paypal und die sind happy, genau, ich bezahle mit Paypal, ich hab das ja auch,
ich hab den sogar angeboten, ich hab da drauf geantwortet, hab gesagt, okay, ich will das,
ich will das Zeug nicht rausgeben, aber wie gesagt, ich bezahle legit, ich kann entweder
vom Paypal Business Account, der verified ist, nochmal überweisen oder ich mach mal deswegen
auch prepaid, wenn sie wollen, aber wollten sie nicht, da hab ich mir gedacht, okay, wenn
ich kein Geld vollste, dann halt nicht, Weishall98, danke für den Sub, exquisite Subscription,
liegt bestimmt am Name, ja der war schon sehr auffällig, der war schon sehr auffällig
der Name, ne, ich hab, ich hab, die haben halt wahrscheinlich gedacht, niemand auf dieser
Welt heißt Peter Wubbel, und dann auch noch mit einer offensichtlichen Fake Telefonnummer,
da haben die sich gedacht, schick mal aus, weil es blitzt, ach, gibt's eigentlich, gibt's
eigentlich mein Xing Account noch, ach ne, Moment, nicht Xing, LinkedIn war das oder,
Kudor Chatte, ach ne, ich weiß, weil Xing Passwort nimmer, ne, ich weiß auch die E-Mail
Adresse nicht mehr, doch hab ich, hab ich, ich hab 3 E-Mails geedit, ich hab, ähm,
die ganzen animierten E-Mails geedit, kann sein, dass die noch nicht reflektiert haben,
alle E-Mails, die animiert waren, hab ich, und Wubzee, mach mal Wubzee, hast du die
gemacht, weil der im Discord hat auch so, so, so, japanische Zeichen, Stels am Start,
Wubzee hab ich direkt drinne, wisst ihr, das warst du, exellent, ich werd das mal nachher
überprüfen, ob das stimmt, aber, mal für den, für den Einsatz, gibt's schonmal Exquisite
Subscription, so muss das sein, kannste deine eigenen E-Mails verwenden, wobei ich hab nur
eins hinzu gemacht, ah, yes, 2 Laurens, dankeschön, 4 Monate, aber die sind doch cool, oder, also,
hatte ich nicht auch so ein Pet, Pet, Wub, Moment, das Wub Pet, das hab ich nicht gefunden,
glaub ich, in Better Twitch TV Emotes, hast du mal nen Link dazu, wenn du einen Link zu
diesem Wub Pet hast, dann mach ich das noch rein, es gab 3, 3, ehm, Wub Pet ist von Rasti,
ah, dann hab ich das vielleicht falsch, sag ich schnell, lullwee, ehm, also, so, also
die haben, die haben gesagt, irgendwie, die waren merkwürdig drauf, so, und, Moment,
am Better Twitch ist es das hier, zeig mal, Wub Pet, genau das brauchen wir, Add to Channel
ist drin, wie war dein Werdegang nach deiner Ausbildung, ne, so viel Werdegang gibt's doch
gar nicht mehr, also, ich hab, ich hab die Ausbildung beim Provider, Alter, warum springt
denn das so hin und her, so, ehm, ich hab die Ausbildung beim Provider gemacht, dann
hab ich danach noch ein bisschen, ich weiß nicht, wie lang ich da noch da gewesen bin,
ein Jahr oder so, nicht so extrem lang, dann haben die ja angefangen diesen Schwachsinn
zu machen, was ich letztens, weiß ich, ob du's gesehen hast, ich hab hier letztens ein Video
zugemacht, wo ich das erzählt hab, wie merkwürdig die drauf gewesen sind, auf einmal, ah, hier,
und dann bin ich gewechselt, also ich hab dann gekündigt und dann bin ich gewechselt,
und ich hatte halt damals den Vorteil, dass ich im Prinzip schon da war, also ich war
ja quasi vermittelt von diesem Provider an einen Dienstleister in Frankfurt, und, ehm,
die haben da was für eine große Bank gemacht, und ich hab jetzt direkt bei der Bank angefangen,
und da bin ich jetzt auch schon seit, ich glaub, acht Jahren, ich bin da schon eine
ganze Weile jetzt, ja, exquisite, ehm, bei dem Rate, mir fällt grad ein, ich mach's
nur mal in Warenkorb, dass ich's nicht vergesse, ich hab ja jetzt ja mein Ploujeti wieder
gefunden, ich hab das irgendwie, ehm, die ganze Zeit auf dem Schreibtisch stehen gehabt,
hab's aber nicht mal gesehen, klingt jetzt bescheuert, war aber so, ich wollt mir einen
Pop-Schutz kaufen, ich mach das nur mal in den Warenkorb, dass ich's nicht vergesse,
was nehm ich denn da, das da, das da, was denn da besser, ich hab's echt nicht gesehen,
Leute, glaubt ihr, das Ploujeti stand die ganze Zeit links auf meinem Schreibtisch,
ja, und ich hab gesucht und gemacht, und ich hab's nicht gefunden, und eines Tages sitz
ich hier mit dem Headset und telefonier mit einem auf der Arbeit, guckst du nach links
und seh mir, ah, guck mal, da steht das Ploujeti, ab da hab ich's gesehen, und ich wollt es
nicht wahrhaben, dass das wohl die ganze Zeit schon da stand, ich war total verwirrt, das
da, also das hier sind ja zwei Stück, komm, ich stell mir jetzt einfach den hier, easy,
easy money, easy life, der Twitch Chat bezahlt es, wie viele Leute haben eigentlich schon
den Post gesucht, gar nicht zu wenig, exellent, exellent, übrigens Notifications vom Preischamp,
by the way, wo wir gerade dabei sind, äh, falls, ne, Beta geht nicht, Beta sollte eigentlich
redirecten, Beta sollte eigentlich redirecten auf normal, ach ne, Quatsch, www sollte redirecten
auf normal, ja, macht's auch, exellent, exellent, ähm, was wollt ich jetzt sagen, Leute, verwirrt,
siehst du mal, ist richtig spumer hier jetzt schon, einmal abgelenkt und schon weiß ich,
was ich sagen will, ja, genau, also, ich weiß wieder, wenn ihr iOS, wenn ihr auf iOS seid,
geht das hier nicht, ihr könnt keine Notifications auf iOS machen, ja, genau, ich hab's 90% rotatet,
ihr könnt keine Notifications auf iOS machen, weil iOS das nicht unterstützt, hab ich,
also wusste ich schon, hab ich jetzt aber mich mal wieder auf den aktuellsten Stand
gebracht und mich extrem gewundert, dass das immer noch so ist, also man muss mal echt
sagen, Apple ist, was Support angeht, für neue Webgedünste total hinten dran, can I,
moin, müsst ihr euch mal angucken, can I use, sagt richtig, ja, also, äh, die haben
doch irgendwie so ne Übersicht gehabt für Browser, warte mal, ok, haben die die Seite
geändert, wenn man jetzt nämlich mal beispielsweise iOS Safari nimmt und das mal compared mit
aktuellen Desktop und aktuellem Android, wo ist der Chrome, der Android Chrome, haben
die gar kein Android Chrome, Android Browser, ok, so, die hatten doch ne schöne Übersicht,
genau, da werdet ihr sehen, dass sowohl Firefox Chrome Desktop als auch Android Browser eigentlich
ziemlich gut sind, aber guckt euch mal an, äh, übrigens Safari und Chrome ist das gleiche
auf iOS, wer sich wundert, warum das hier oben zusammen drin steht, dass, ähm, das
verwirrt ja immer viele Leute, wenn ich sag, dass Safari und Chrome unter iOS das gleiche
ist, aber es ist nun mal so, dass, äh, die Render Engine ist überall Safari, ist egal,
ob man Chrome oder Firefox verwendet, unter iOS gibt's nur Safari, so, und guckt mal,
hier geht's schon los, nur partial supported, partial supported, partial supported, no, no,
no, no, no, no, also, der sagt mal richtig, also Safari auf iOS ist so ne Kackbrowser,
leider gibt's nix anderes, das ist ja das Problem, unter iOS gibt es keinen anderen
Browser als Safari, gibt es dort wenigstens eine Alternative und sei es auch nur ein echter
Firefox, aber gibt's nicht, tja, darum nutze ich native Debian auf dem Handy, ja, das viel
Spaß auf dem iPhone, echt beizuschrecken, nice, ist Chrome auf iOS da nur ein Skin,
im Prinzip ja, Chrome, Chrome, Brave, Firefox, Opera, was es nicht alles gibt, alle Browser
auf iOS sind Safari Reskills, ist jetzt kein, ist wirklich so, deswegen sacken, sackt es
auch so, und gerade in Bezug auf PWAs, was jetzt für mich ja praktisch schwer ist, ist
halt total hinten dran, ich hab mal geguckt, ich hab mal geguckt, wie ich möglichst einfach
den Preischamp unter, unter iOS zum Beispiel mit Notifications ausstatten könnte, und
es gibt eigentlich nur eine sinnvolle Variante, man nimmt einen, man nimmt einen, einen Converter,
der Webseiten zu einer App quasi convertet, sowas da zum Beispiel, also ich hab das letztendlich
auch mal im Stream gepostet, ist eigentlich richtig nice, und dann baut man native Notifications
ein, nachdem man das konvertiert hat für iOS, dazu braucht man einen Apple Developer Account,
muss sich registrieren bei Apple und muss glaube ich auch irgendwelche Sachen, Beantragungen
machen und sowieso, man muss Geld bezahlen und man braucht einen Mac mit Xcode, dass
man das abschließend kompilieren und signen kann, oder kompilieren, weil ich aber abschließend
signen kann, braucht man einen Mac und Xcode, also sprich Apple hat sich gedacht, niemand
möchte sicherlich mit einem anderen Gerät als mit einem Mac iOS Anwendungen entwickeln
und deswegen geht das nicht, tja perfekt, das heißt, das mach ich vielleicht mal aus
educational Zwecken, aber in nächster Zeit eher nicht, also Apple ist da, ist bescheuert
ja, ist total hängen geblieben, das kann man machen, das werd ich auch machen, ich
kauf mir ja keinen Apple, keinen Mac, ja hab ich, genau, das hab ich ausprobiert ja, also
warum ich das gemacht hab ist folgendes, ich hab mir einen Hetzer Server geholt mit 10
Public IPs und hab den Squid so eingestellt, dass jeder Request random eine von diesen
IPs als Ausgang bekommt, das hab ich gemacht, dass mein Website-Crawler nicht so oft in
Cloudflare und Sachen läuft, allerdings ich selbst bin natürlich hinter Cloudflare, weiß
jemand auf welchem G-Pay habe ich die LEDs auf, also der Arzt Delivery Delivered nur,
du musst gucken, du musst gucken, welchen ESP32 du hast, Isle, schickt mal einen Link
oder sag mal den Namen von dem ESP32, da kann ich dir auch was zu dem GPIO aussagen und
schreib atwupplos davor, sonst seh ichs vielleicht nicht, ja ist es, ist es, glaub ich hab sonst
nix übersehen oder, was der Schriftzug ist über der Lupe in einem Mobilpro, ernsthaft,
das testen wir jetzt mal, naja es ist zu verschmerzen würde ich sagen, oder führt das direkt zum
uninstall, was meint ihr Leute, direkt uninstall oder, by the way das Wackel ist auch noch
kaputt, wie ist kein 3080 verfügbar, keck wait, wo ist die hin, ja wahrscheinlich 15
Minuten Timeout oder so, sag ist Intended, na gut Intended hat bei Snapchat auch funktioniert,
Snapchat, weiß ich nicht ob ihr das mitgekriegt habt, Snapchat ist seit Jahren kacke zu bedienen
und die haben mal ein Update gebracht, dass Snapchat ein bisschen normaler sich bedienen
lässt und die Leute sind voll auf die Parikanen gestiegen und haben rein weiß Snapchat verlassen,
bis Snapchat gesagt hat, wir machen die App wieder, reverten wir zu scheiße zurück, dann
sind die Leute wieder da, Verbraucherschutz schon kontaktiert wegen der Lupe über dem
Logo, naja das ist kritisch, das gute ist bei meiner Website, ich hab keine Cookies,
ich hab nix, ich speicher keine IPs und sonst was, ich brauch kein Cookie Banner, ich brauch
kein DSGVO Banner, ich brauch nix, hast du eine Idee für ein Viewproject, kann ich
gleich was zu sagen, ja die benachrichtigen kannst du mit 50er Schritten, ich hab mir
gedacht bei Hardwarepreisen von immer 500 Euro plus reichen 50er Schritte, Arts Delivered
ESP Dev Kit V2, Moment ich gucke mal, Snapchat ist eh tut sein Instagram Stories, ernsthaft,
Snapchat schicken die nicht immer noch ihre nackt Fotos, weil man die angeblich automatisch
löschen kann und nicht wieder herstellend, also das da, was ist das für ein Teil, ah
das ist, das sieht aus wie, das ist eine Nordsee MCU, das Ding hast du, Ise, ist das das Ding,
dann hast du Glück, weil das so ziemlich eines der besten und verbreitetsten ESP32s ist,
da gibst du einfach ein ESP32 Pinout, gehst mal auf Bilder und nimmst dir dann irgendeins,
was nach dem Board aussieht, das ist es alles nicht, hallo, bin ich jetzt, oh der, ah guck
mal, die Leute haben schon was am Start, what, nein, das ist was anderes, das hier kannst
du wahrscheinlich nehmen, aber, ja, das, das, fuck, zumindest du brauchst so einen, ne,
ein ESP32s ist es übrigens nicht, ja, ich glaube, denke mal, das hier ist eigentlich
ganz gut, ja, du brauchst so ein Pinout Board, wohlgemerkt, du brauchst das ESP32, nicht
das ESP32s, das ESP32s ist ein anderer, äh, was ist dein Front und Backend beim Preischirm,
kann ich gleich was zu sagen, genau, also brauchst du einen Pinout, sowas hier musst du dir
raussuchen, weil die Bezeichnung in der IDE und auf dem Board ist nicht unbedingt immer,
sondern nicht konsistent, bei Arduino hießen die Pins immer D123 irgendwas und nummeriert
sind sie hier als GPIO, es heißt aber nicht unbedingt, dass wenn jetzt auf dem Board hier
steht 26, dass das GPIO 26 ist, beim Node, äh, beim NodeMCU ist es glaube ich so, aber
es gibt Boards, da steht hier keine Ahnung 8 dran und es ist GPIO 25, das ergibt keinen
Sinn, ja, das heißt du brauchst immer so ein Pinout Board und in dem Fall, ähm, kannst
du dann in deiner IDE quasi so, ich glaube GPIO underscore 23 oder so heißen die Dinger,
die du verwenden kannst, ist bisschen durch die Brust ins Auge, aber es funktioniert schon,
ja genau, das da braucht man, ja, richtig, sowas hier, wobei das Pinout ist, naja, ok,
man erkennt alles, man erkennt alles, der angezeigte Preis, ja, da kann ich aber nichts
machen, manche Shops, manche Shops, ähm, lassen sich nicht richtig parsen, Expert ist
einer dabei, da muss man ein paar Tage warten, bis das im Crawler gefixt ist, so, also, was
gab's eben noch für nice Questions, was ist mit der Handy, ja, ok, ich geh mal der Reihe
nach die Sachen durch, ich sag zu allem was, also, äh, ich muss jetzt so langsam gucken,
dass ich nichts übersehe, also, also, zeig mal her, ähm, also, was ist mit der Handy-App,
die du freiwillig auf der Arbeit machen wolltest, die hab ich gemacht, das war, wer es nicht
mitgekriegt hat, das war so ein freiwilliges, äh, CodeCamp oder BarcodeCamp, oder wie auch
immer das jetzt genau heißt, was die Firma, wo ich arbeite, am Wochenende gemacht hat,
und ich hab's ja schonmal erzählt, deswegen, deswegen jetzt nur ganz kurz, im Vorfeld
haben die das allen gekündigt, so, als übelstes, äh, Hexor-Event, ja, so nach dem Motto, äh,
man soll gucken, dass man eine funktionierende Arduino, äh, nicht Arduino, was lab ich denn,
eine funktionierende Android-IDE beziehungsweise Android-Emulator hat und so was, und da hab
ich mir gedacht, oh nice, das ist genau was für mich, hab ich mich angemeldet, hab ich
noch, äh, drei Mitstreiterinnen gesucht, äh, ne, vier, vier, stimmt gar nicht, vier
Stück, wir waren insgesamt fünf, die Teamgröße war maximal fünf, und da haben wir uns angemeldet
und haben unsere App-Idee eingereicht und haben dann angefangen, einen Prototyp zu basteln,
der ist auch richtig cool gewesen, ich würde ihn euch zeigen, kann ich nicht, das lieg
ich zu viel von der Firma, war richtig nice, und am Ende sollte man das Ganze vorstellen,
so, und jetzt passt mal auf, es waren, glaub ich, 15 oder 16 Teams, und von diesen 16,
was meint ihr, ich frage euch mal, Chet, ich weiß, ich hab's schon erzählt, aber ein paar,
also, was meint ihr, wie viel von diesen 16 Teams den funktionierenden Prototyp hatten?
Wo man drinnen rumklicken kann und sich angucken kann, wie's gedacht ist.
Ja, Chet, ihr liegt zum größten Teil richtig, wir waren die einzigen, wir haben uns halt
das gemacht, wie das Ganze ausgesehen hat, wir haben halt einfach Hacker-Mans gemacht,
ja, so, Hacker-Mans gemacht, da konnten natürlich die Stonks-Typen nicht mithalten, und so,
und jetzt, und jetzt, und jetzt kommt's, unser Team war auch nur fünf, also, maximal
Teamgröße war ja auch fünf, so, und am Ende sollte man dann so ein dreiminütiges Vorstellungsvideo
machen, hab ich aufgenommen mit meinem hier Pro-Aufnahme-Equipment, aber ich hab halt
gleich gesagt in dem Video, gut, ist jetzt nicht viel Zeit, deswegen komm ich gleich
zum Punkt, so und so haben wir uns die App vorgestellt, hier kann man das gucken, hier
kann man hier in das gucken, hier kriegt man direkt dann was angezeigt, wenn man angerufen
wird, sonst was, also eigentlich richtig inhaltsbezogen, ja, Shandam, Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub,
also eigentlich so genau so, wie ich mir vorgestellt hab, dass das Ganze, dass das Ganze laufen
muss, so, und jetzt kommt's, wisst ihr, wer gewonnen hat, nicht wir, die bei so einem
Hacking-Wettbewerb den einzigen funktionierenden Prototyp hatten, nein, es hat jemand gewonnen,
der keinerlei Prototyp hatte, und nur eine richtig cool animierte Präsentation gemacht
hat, und die sieben Leute von fünf erlaubten Leuten waren, wo man sich dann fragt, okay,
den Kram hätte man sich auch echt sparen können, die hatten im Endeffekt, die haben
wahrscheinlich zwei Tage lang einfach nur Präsentation gemacht, und es war eine Präsentation,
kennt ihr diese Präsentationen, die in so Richtung gehen wie, das ist der Twitch-Chat,
der Twitch-Chat ist unglücklich, weil er keine schönen Emotes hat, seitdem der Max
Emotes hochgeladen ist, ist der Twitch-Chat glücklich, und deswegen ist der Max auch
glücklich, kennt ihr solche Videos, so ein Video haben die gemacht, für ihre App-Idee,
so nach dem Motto, das ist der Außendienst-Mitarbeiter, der ist furchtbar unglücklich, wenn er nicht
weiß, wer ihn anruft, und mit unserer App ist er glücklich, so nach dem Motto haben
die das gemacht, das war auch die gleiche, eine ziemlich ähnliche Idee zu unserer,
und die haben gewonnen, tja, wo man mal wieder sieht, Stonks größer Technik, und es waren
sieben statt fünf, was halt auch ein bisschen fail ist, weil mal ganz im Ernst, hätten
wir auch sieben Leute genommen, da hätte ich mir noch zwei Stück aus irgendeiner Marketing-Stonks-Abteilung
rausgesucht, die einfach nur schöne Präsentationsvideos machen können, oder hätten wir auch eine
geile Präsentation gehabt, aber nee, wir haben den Fehler gemacht, zwar ich, der Felix,
den kennt ihr ja vielleicht noch von ein paar Videos, da noch einer, mit dem ich mich auch
auf der Arbeit gut verstehe, zwei noch weiter, und noch eine aus der QS, die ziemlich gut
weiß, wie unser Außendienst so arbeitet, die war auch noch dabei, und wir haben halt
wirklich drauf geachtet, dass wir das sinnvoll machen, und auch so implementieren, dass man
eben sieht, was passiert, wenn man wo draufklickt und so was, genau, und im Endeffekt ging es
da überhaupt nicht da dran, auch wenn die so getan haben, so nach dem Motto, das muss
Hacker-Man sein, war es halt nicht, es war im Prinzip nur Stonks-Präsentation, das heißt
das nächste Mal, sollte ich damit machen, mache ich das auch so, da sage ich einfach,
okay, wir machen einfach drei Bildchen, und sprechen 250 mal das Präsentationsvideo ein,
das sich gut anhört.
Jetzt erzählen sie, es kommt darauf an, wie man das Event verkauft, wenn du das als Business
Stonks, ihr müsst was verkaufen, Event verkaufst am Anfang, dann ist das ja okay, aber wenn
du in die Einladung reinschreibst, was von wegen Android IDE und Android Emulator und
Prototyp und sonst was, und dann ist man der Einzige, der quasi so was in der Richtung
macht, also da muss man sich halt überlegen, wie man das anpreist im Vorfeld, weil wenn
von Anfang an klar gewesen wäre, dass wir so ein geiles Stonks Business Event hätte,
hätte ich da halt mitgemacht.
Aber natürlich, vielleicht hört man ein bisschen raus, dass ich Scheiße finde, dass wir nicht
gewonnen haben, aber dann kann man ja nichts machen, wenn ich mal so was mitmache, mache
ich mit, weil ich gewonnen, weil ich gewinnen will.
So, also hätten wir das geklärt, ja, das sagt Apple tatsächlich, was ist denn, Ducker Go,
du meinst Duck Duck Go, Duck Duck Go ist eine Suchmaschine, es ging ja um einen Ersatz Chrome,
ja.
Achso, das habe ich ja schon beantwortet.
Das stimmt, das habe ich nie gesagt, dass ich mir kein Apple kaufe.
Günstig, ja, das ist bestimmt äußerst günstig, was kostet denn das, 4000 Euro, du hast die
Emotes deleted, ok, was mache ich denn jetzt, ich habe die mir noch gar nicht alle fertig
angeguckt, also, beispielsweise den Clown Wub wollte ich auch, aber gut, die sind ja
im Discord drin, oder, sind die im Discord drin, sind die Bilder im Discord drin, Wubz
Dat und solche Dinger, also wenn die Bilder im Discord drin sind, dann brauchst du die
auch nicht als Bella Twitch TV, ich wollte noch mal gucken, ob ich davon noch was nehme
und in den Channel reinmache, also ich muss, was echt geil wäre, wäre ein Wub Ayaya,
oder auch das mit dem Herz, aber das ist irgendwie, irgendwie sagt es mir noch nicht hundertprozentig
zu das Ayaya-Emote, wobei so ein Ayaya-Emote cool wäre, Wub Wub Ayaya, oder Wub Wub Keg
W oder irgendwie sowas, also es wäre, es wäre nice, wenn du mir die noch mal als Bilder
im Discord posten könntest, dass ich sie im Zweifelsfall nehmen kann, weil ich muss
mir noch mal in Ruhe angucken, habe ich denn überhaupt die Rechte, die zu nehmen, Keg
Wade, also, genau, das hatten wir schon, ich wollte jetzt zu einigen Dingern noch was sagen,
ja, das ist Absicht, hast du eine Idee für ein View-Produkt, boah, ne, das ergibt sich
meistens so aus dem, was ich, was ich machen will, mittlerweile brauche ich ja eh fast jede
Anwendung, du brauchst die Slots, ja ja, lass die, lass die ruhig aus Bella Twitch TV oder
FFZ weg, ja, du hast doch die Bilder noch bei dir lokal, oder? Schick mir doch, schick,
ne, ne, schick, was ich meine, ist nicht die Links zu Bella Twitch TV, die, die, die Emotes,
die, die PNGs in, in Discord, da kann ich die noch mal alle angucken, track and drop einfach
die ganzen PNGs mal in Discord oder schickst dem sie Baro, wenn du die nicht public, äh,
wenn du die nicht public haben willst, weil ich meine, du hast dir so viel Mühe dabei
gegeben, wäre doch blöd jetzt alles zu löschen, oder? Also ich meine, wie gesagt, bei der
Twitch TV kannst du ja weglassen, aber halt die PNGs, du hast die, du hast die ernsthaft
gelöscht alle? Okay, dann, gag wait, also wenn du die neu machst, wenn du die neu machst,
mach mal langsam, wenn du die neu machst, also das, so ein Herz und Eier Eier Emote wäre
echt nice, da müssten wir uns aber vielleicht, also wenn du da Bock drauf hast, müssten
wir uns da mal, aber Gedanken zu machen, weil das hat mir nicht so hundertprozentig zugesagt,
und ich will ja nur nice Emotes only, also was heißt nice, nice sind die, gibt's ja
viele, aber halt nur welche, die mir so hundertprozentig zusagen haben. Okay, also weiter, ähm, also
was ist dein Front und Backend beim Preischamp? Frontend ist Vue.js, Backend ist ASP.NET Core
und der Crawler ist eine Node.js Anwendung, die ist aber nicht von mir. Kennst du eine
gute Internetseite, wo man die Physi Prüfung üben kann? Ja, du suchst dir einfach den
Download der letzten 20 Physi Übungen als PDF und machst die, darf man hier aber nicht
die Bilder? Da kann ich mir die mal in Ruhe angucken. So, ähm, genau. Ja, wie gesagt,
kann manchen sagen, kann das falsch sein. Mach mal eine Chrome-Extension, den neuen
mit dem alten, das ist jetzt, mich wundert's, dass es, dass es FFZ noch nicht eingebaut
hat oder BT, BTTV, ach so, ja, ich, doch, ich weiß, warum die das eingebaut haben, weil
das Copyright am alten POG-Champ wahrscheinlich bei Twitch linken, die konnten das nicht machen.
Äh, Shandam, danke für den Sub, wobei hab ich glaube ich schon vorgelesen, oder? Macht
nix, ja, doppelt machen. Also, ich muss sagen, es gibt bei uns mittlerweile relativ viele
ältere, da sind auch viele dabei, die nix checken, das stimmt schon, aber es gibt auch
erstaunlicherweise viele Leute, die was checken. Ich mein, darf nicht vergessen, ich bin in
vier Jahren auch über 40, ja. Keck Wade. Nix gegen 40-Jährige. Äh, AI Pro, ja, äh,
ohne Scheiß soll ich dir was sagen, Silicon, wir haben uns auch überlegt, ob wir entweder
ein sinnvolles Projekt machen oder irgendein Projekt, was sich einfach nur geil anhört.
So, irgendwie nach dem Motto Machine Learning Analyse zum besseren Verkaufen von Verträgen
oder irgendwas. Ach, das ist Wii Fit, schon gewundert. Welches ist der beste Browser?
Tja, hättest du mich das vor ein paar Jahren gefragt, dann hätt ich gesagt, nimm Firefox,
allerdings macht sich Firefox ja jetzt schon seit ein paar Jahren, zerstört sich Firefox
ja selber. Deswegen, es bleibt eigentlich nur Chrome. Oder eine der x-beliebigen Chrome
Varianten. Vivaldi ist auch eine Chrome Variante. Ah, Vivaldi ist cool, das stimmt. Hab ich
das nicht sogar schon noch drauf? Vivaldi ist echt nice, ja. Edge, ne, hör mal auf.
Aber es gibt ja im Prinzip nur noch die Auswahl zwischen Firefox und Chrome. Edge gibt's ja
nicht mehr. Und wenn ich wirklich was aussuchen müsste, wo ich immer das Aktuellste krieg
und immer irgendwie die Seiten so gemacht sind, mittlerweile, dass sie gehen, dann würde
ich einfach Chrome nehmen. Ja, du kannst aber auch irgendeinen Chrome Abkömmling verwenden,
ja, das geht auch. Früher hätt ich gesagt, Firefox, aber es ist echt doof, wie sehr Firefox
es verschissen hat in den letzten Jahren. Guckt euch das GUI an, guckt euch den eingestellten
Support für Extensions an, guckt euch die Sachen an, dass die keinen Bock mehr haben,
neue Sachen zu unterstützen, wo sie mal Vorreiter waren. Ich weiß auch nicht, ist Firefox zerstört
nach und nach jeden Grund, warum man Firefox verwenden sollte. Das einzige, was Firefox
noch richtig gut macht, sind die DevTools und da gibt's auch nicht mal viel, was Chrome
nicht kann, eher so umgedreht. Extensions sind auf dem Niveau von Chrome, ja, aber die
waren früher besser als Chrome. Es ist ja nicht die Frage, wie man auf dem Niveau von,
es reicht ja nicht, wenn man einen alternativen Browser anbietet, gleich gut zu sein. Man
muss ja eigentlich was besser machen und die Firefox Extensions früher waren um Längen
besser als die Chrome Extensions, zumindest was du machen konntest, aber mittlerweile
gibt's das halt nicht mehr. Guckt ihr das alte, guckt ihr das alte NoScript an, guckt
ihr das neue NoScript an, richtig verkackt. Chrome ist auch Open Source, bis auf ein paar
Teile. Es sind, was weiß ich, die Chromecast-Geschichte und so, aber im Prinzip ist der Großteil
von Google auch Open Source, von Chrome, nicht von Google. Das alte NoScript war das beste.
Jaja, klar, hab ich das mitgekriegt. Äh, ja, alles okay. Oh, oh Mist, da fällt mir
grad was ein. Der hat mich gestern Abend angerufen und ich hab's, also ich hab's zu spät gesehen
und ich wollte ihn heute eigentlich anrufen. Moin, Herr Max, kommst du montags mir helfen
beim Obziehen? Ähm, du kannst, nein, nein, ich sag's jetzt nicht, sonst machst du das
noch. Also, ich sag's nicht. Ich wollte sagen, aus Spaß, weil ich mir gedacht hab, es macht
doch eh keiner, wollte ich sagen, schreibt die Adresse in den Chat und die Leute kommen,
aber mach das bloß nicht, mach das bloß nicht. Gibt genug Sachen, wo das nach hinten losgegangen
ist, ey. Hätte der Drachenlord mal nie seine Adresse geleakt, da wär das alles nicht so
eskaliert, äh. So, was haben wir denn sonst noch? By the way, ich hab so ein Plugin, das
zeigt eigentlich, ach nee, das hab ich auf dem anderen Rechner, das zeigt an beim Hovern.
Katzma, Dankeschön für den Sub, exquisite Subscription. Sehr gut, exellent. Hey Max,
ich benutze an meinem Fernseher einen HDMI-Switch, hab gehört, dadurch geht die Latenz, nee.
Nee. Wenn das einfach nur ein blöder HDMI-Switch ist, der nix macht, dann ist das ja im Endeffekt
nix anderes, wie wenn du umsteckst das Kabel. Da gibt's keine große Alge Latenz. Ich hab
mir jetzt als kompletter Linux-Sub mit einem Raspberry Pi 4 ein Nass gebastelt. Was kannst
du mit dem Gerät noch tolles anstellen? Ja, so ziemlich alles außer Nass. Für den Nass
ist der Raspberry Pi 4 sackt. Also der ist wirklich, der Raspberry Pi 4 als Nass ist
sackt wirklich. Es gibt viele Geräte, die besser einsehen als ein Raspberry Pi. Nicht
nur die Bandbreite, das größte Problem ist, dass die Acrypto Extensions gespart haben
fürs Raspberry Pi 4. Vue.js Frontend hab ich doch schon gesagt. Also bei mir ergibt sich
das immer so. Bei mir ergibt sich das immer so, wenn ich was brauch. Speziell fällt mir
da nix ein, nee. Gut, das hab ich ja schon aufgezählt grad. Ja, aber richtig. Nee,
weiß ich nicht. Ey, du kannst Venice spielen, wo wir grad dabei sind. Mal gucken, ob die
Server noch voll sind, weil mittlerweile ist es glaub ich ziemlich RIP. Gucken, ob's Server
noch gibt. Noch nicht mal ein Server richtig voll. Ja, das Problem ist, dass es sich mittlerweile
rumgesprochen hat und die letzten Tage, wo ich gespielt hab, war halt auch schon richtig
merkwürdiges Zeug dabei. Von Leuten, die gecheatet haben, bis halt sehr sketchy Dinger,
die passiert sind. Teilweise, wo ich mir gedacht hab, ist die vielleicht sogar admin selbst,
aber der hat mir nicht sogar selbst an. Ja. Da müssten echt die Leute richtig gut den
Server administrieren. Richt PP Guard. Richt PP Guard Server, so rum. Ich komm mit dem Chat
an. Exzellente Idee. Ich bin all Twitch Subs in. Nice, Sebaro. Der Sebaro ist einfach
der beste Mod. Max, welchen Instant-Messenger benutzt du? WhatsApps, wie immer. Ratet mal,
welchen Messenger ich verwende, Chat. Ihr kennt mich mittlerweile und ihr wisst das meistens
auch bevor ich sage. Außer ICQ, außer ICQ. Ja, Discord zähl ich jetzt mal nicht dabei.
Okay, alle falsch. Doch, der Calv ist richtig. Ich verwende gar keine Messenger. Das Einzige,
was ich verwende, ist Discord und teilweise Teams. Aber ansonsten, ich hab Signal, allerdings
haben die mich schon gleich wieder geschockt. Direkt, als ich das Ding installiert hab. Ich
hab das installiert, weil wir eine Gruppe auf der Arbeit gemacht haben und auf einmal
labern mich wildfremde Leute, also was heißt wildfremde Leute, Leute, die ich kenne, die
ich in meiner Kontaktliste hab, labern mich auf einmal an. Max, du hast jetzt auch Signal,
hab ich gesehen. Da hab ich mir gedacht, hä? Ich hab extra beim Starten gesagt, ich will
mein Adressbuch nicht uploaden. Ich will mein Adressbuch nicht sharen. Warum machen die
den Scheiß automatisch? Ich will nicht, dass die die Leute benachrichtigen, dass ich jetzt
Signal hab. Total hängen geblieben. Kannste nix dagegen machen. Das ist total Cancer-Scheiß,
Alter. Also WhatsApp ist halt das Ding, ganz im Ernst. Wenn ich was benutzen würde, also
wenn ich wirklich Bedarf für einen Messenger hätte, würde ich ohne Scheiß, würde ich
wahrscheinlich WhatsApp benutzen, weil wenn ich Bedarf für einen Messenger hätte, dann
würde ich ja mit Leuten messagingen wollen und die haben halt nur mal alle WhatsApp.
Mit Streamer und Telegram vielleicht noch ein bisschen, aber du hast im Prinzip, WhatsApp
hat jeder. Deswegen kommt eigentlich der WhatsApp nicht vorbei und jetzt wo sie alle rumgeheult
haben, so nach dem Motto, oh nein, WhatsApp, neue Benutzerbedingungen, Facebook böse und
sonst was. Der Sack ist wieder am Starten, wenn wir unsere Daten haben. Das interessiert
dir jetzt schon keinen mehr. Du sollst ein Mess... ja, programmieren Messenger, der Qt-Chat
heißt, sehr gute Idee. Den musst du für alle Weeps vermarkten, dann setzt er sich durch.
Der einzige Messenger mit regelmäßigen Hentai Pop-Ups oder was auch immer, lässt sich bestimmt
gut verkaufen. Kaufst du die Lizenz bei irgendwelchen Twitter-Artists, da ist das billig oder holst
du immer Pfeifer. Macht eigentlich der Preis-Champ, geht er noch? Exzellent. Was sagen die Leute
auf Twitter zu? Gerade mal nachher gucken, ob irgendwas neues gekommen ist. Kann man
Twitter mittlerweile eigentlich nicht sortieren nach Datum, nach Eingangs? Oh, der alte Toxic,
der alte Pok-Champ, ey. Genau. Ja, korrekt, so sieht's aus. Also wenn du wirklich nass
basteln willst, dann selbst bau nass, dann nimm den Low-Power-Intel-Plattform. Der ist
um einiges schneller, um ein Vielfaches schneller, als der Raspberry Pi, hat Krypto-Extension,
also kann schnell die Sachen, die und Verschluss und hat bessere Bandbreite. Braucht auch nicht
so viel weniger Strom, äh, nicht so viel mehr Strom. Hier ist nix. Dankeschön für die
zwei Monate Subscriptions. Ich komm mit dem Chat echt nicht hinterher heute. Programmiere
Q-Chat, beste. Beste Idee. Websockets. Klar, Websockets. Wenn du willst, dass es irgendjemand
verwendet, Websockets. Keiner, keiner macht heut mal native Apps, alles web und im Zweifelsfall
Elektronen-Apps, dass eine Notiz-App 4GB RAM braucht. Ähm, naja, die Server waren ein
bisschen merkwürdig administriert. Ja, ich hab nen Server bei Ionos. Wie gesagt, überall
hatten sie keine Probleme, bei Ionos nicht, bei Hetzer nicht, bei meinem Domain-Registrar
nicht, bei... Ich weiß gar nicht, vielleicht ist das auch alles, aber ich... Nee, ja Digital
Ocean nicht, äh, bei egal wo. Nirgendwo hatten sie Probleme mit meinem Fake-Namen. Nur bei
OVH wollten sie meine Ausweis-Kopie, dass ich nicht... Ob ich wirklich Peter Wubbel heiße,
Alter. Wie kann man überhaupt daran zweifeln? Glauben die nicht, dass man Peter Wubbel heißen
kann und so richtig schöne Fake-Telefonnummer hat? Unverständlich. Wie verbindet ihr analoge
Sensoren mit dem Raspberry Pi einfach an? Also wenn du analoge Sensoren verwenden willst,
nimm den ESP32, der hat nämlich, glaub ich, zwei, also er hat ziemlich viele ADC-Pins.
Guck hier, du hast zwei ADCs mit jeweils, was weiß ich, wie vielen Channels. Also nimm
so drei Euro 50, vier Euro 50, ESP32, für analoge Sensoren sind die Poggers. Ich weiß
gar nicht, ob der Raspberry Pi überhaupt Pins dafür hat. Hat der das? Weiß ich gar
nicht. Glaub nicht, oder? Nee. Der neue Pico, der neue Pico ist ja kein Raspberry Pi. Hab
ich schon nicht ausprobiert. Ich habs gleich chat, ich bin gleich ran gescrollt. Ja, die
sind aber ratzfatz alle wieder bei WhatsApp. Hast du ein Video, wo du erklärst, wie dein
System aufgebaut ist mit Linux und Windows? Na gut, Windows muss ich glaub ich nicht großartig
erklären. Aber ich hab ein Video, wo ich mein Linux-VM einrichte. Ja, das ist im Archiv.
Guck mal, wo bloß? Da gibt's den Archiv-Knopf, da gehste drauf, kommst zu Google Drive. Telegram,
das Spiegel wieder. Telegram ist doch für Rassisten und Verschwörer. Ja, wenn man so
der normalen Berichterstattung glaubt, ist ja mittlerweile gefühlt alles für Rassisten
und Verschwörer. Ich fand's so geil, wie sich das entwickelt hat mittlerweile. Mittlerweile
ist es so, es reicht nicht mehr das, was rechts ist, es reicht nicht mehr das, was Verschwörungstheorie
ist. Mittlerweile ist alles, was einem nicht mehr gefällt, rechte Verschwörungstheorie.
Ich mein, ey wir sind uns einig, Flat Earth ist ne Verschwörungstheorie. Naja, ich weiß
nicht überhaupt, ob Flat Earth ne Verschwörungstheorie ist, aber könnte man sagen. Aber ich mein,
rechts ist sie ja nett. Ich mein, was ist das? Die haben einen Knall, aber ansonsten.
Also hier siehst du das Archiv und da kannst du dann hier in den Einzelordnern gucken und
die Videos gucken. Da hab ich auch irgendwo Lidungsformen eingerichtet. Ja, das nervt
mich bei Twitter auch. Twitter hält sich aber noch zurück, aber früher konntest du
Twitter rein chronologisch machen, mittlerweile nicht mehr. Ich dachte mir, der Name klingt
noch realistischer als irgendwie Peter Wubblors oder so. Könnte sogar sein, als Peter Wubblors
heiße bei denen. Das ist auch nice, ja. Oh, ich bin fast ran gescrollt, Leute. Kannst
du mal die Heizungssteuerung zeigen? Und ich schon wieder, oder? Chat, stopp die Zeit,
die Heizungssteuerung überspringen wir halt mal. Wir könnten uns alternativ, wenn ihr
wollt, wenn ihr wollt, könnten wir uns die Statistikseite vom PreisChamp angucken, das
Grafana Dashboard vom PreisChamp. Okay Leute, wir gucken uns das Grafana Dashboard vom PreisChamp
an. Da ist es. Exzellent, exzellent. Kannst du was zu deinem Lokal... Ja, ich hab die
einfach in meinem Router-DNS gesetzt. So, das ist die Grafana-Seite vom PreisChamp.
Gucken wir mal in den letzten drei Stunden. Ah ja, exzellent, exzellent. Verstehe, verstehe.
Ah, jetzt... Aua, dieser... Ah Leute, dieser Peak hier, der macht mir ja Gedanken. Das
ist highly critical. Aber was ich ganz cool finde, was man hier sieht, dass das Ding erst
mal 16 Kerne hat und trotzdem erst mal zu 40% ausgelastet ist. Also, der crawlt schon ordentlich.
Der crawlt schon ordentlich. Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was ich eigentlich vorhatte, Leute? Warum
ich mir bei Ophahorn einen Server mieten wollte? Ich wollte das folgendermaßen machen und
zwar... Also, was ich mir gedacht hab, ist... Ich kauf mir den hier, da kommt mein Frontend
und meine ASP-Dornett-Anwendung drauf und den Crawler lass ich auf einem 8-Kerner von
Hetzner laufen. Oder, was ich heute auch noch gesehen hab, aber wo ich mir gedacht hab,
das muss ich mir eigentlich nicht geben, kennt noch jemand Strato? Was läuft auf WhoAmI,
kann ich dir zeigen? Ach, nicht WhoAmI, WhoIs, lul. Da läuft, da läuft, gibt's nicht. Und
wenn du sehen würdest, wird da Peter Wubbel drinstehen, weil keiner stört sich an meinem
Fake-Namen außer Ophahorn. So, und, also wie gesagt, mein eigentlicher Plan war, 4 Kerner
hiervon für quasi Frontend und, ja, Backend-Anwendung und den Crawler auf den Hetzner. Das wäre
auch viel billiger. Ich mein, ihr dürft mich vergessen, der Hetzner-Server kostet mich
60 Euro im Monat plus 10 IPs sind noch mal 11 Euro oder so. Also ich bezahl quasi 72-73
Euro Grad Servergebühren. Das lass ich jetzt mal, bis ich das ein bisschen eingependelt
hab, aber dann scale ich das wieder runter, weil das seh ich nicht ein. Es sei denn, es
macht huge money, aber dafür müsste ich mehr Reflinks machen. Macht auch Pornwerbung
oder AdSense. Vielleicht mach ich AdSense. AdSense ist glaub ich recht dezent. Ja. Warum
nicht einer von den großen, weil AWS und Azure übelst teuer sind, was VMs angeht.
Was so schwer ist, Reflinks, man muss erstmal Reflinks bekommen. Ich hab Reflinks von Amazon,
die kann ich aber nicht einbauen in Sachen, die zu was weiß ich, Mindfactory zeigen oder
so. Das heißt, ich muss jetzt erstmal gucken, dass ich, ob die überhaupt nen Partnerprogramm
haben. Also Alternate und Mindfactory haben eins und da muss ich mich erstmal registrieren.
Oder ich mach AdFly. Kennen doch jemand AdFly? Nee, das ist fail, das mach ich nicht, so
ne kacke. Genau, Strato, alter. Gibt's VPS, Linux, Strato, was haben die da am Start?
Ein Core? Wie? Warum haben die nur Server mit einem Core?
Nee, das war's. Ah, nee. Okay, Alter, man kann's auch, nee. Hä? Die müssen, die müssen
doch mehr haben. Die müssen, ernsthaft, die müssen doch mehr haben als eins, ja, okay,
vServer, Linux. Ah, jetzt sind's andere. Hä? Cacquade? Sind Mini-Server, ja, sieht
auch so aus. Also, genau. Hey, das ist echt günstig. Das ist echt günstig. Strato, alter.
Okay, da ist, da ist keine Public IP oder eh, irgendwas ist da der Haken. Irgendwas
ist da der Haken. Also, alles was billiger ist als Hetzner, da mach ich mir Gedanken
einfach, wo der Haken ist. Achso, ja, okay, ein Monat. Ja, aber 22 Euro ist auch absolut
nix. 48 Gigabyte RAM für 22 Euro im Monat? Ich würd sagen, das müssen wir ausprobieren
in einem der nächsten Streams. Contabo hab ich mir nie angeguckt. Ähm, wir probieren
mal Strato aus in einem der nächsten Streams. Da hab ich, da hab ich so meine Zweifel, dass
da, da machen wir mal IO-Tests und Übertragungstests und alles möglich, da, ich hab da meine Zweifel,
dass das alles, ähm, na klar sind das, sind das virtuelle. Ja, bei Hetzner ist das auch
alles virtuell. KVM ist bei Hetzner zumindest. Äh, aber Hetzner hat das nicht so krass
überbucht, also man kann das ganz gut, äh, ganz gut, äh, auch IO-mäßig. IO-sackt, na,
IO würd ich jetzt gar nicht so sehr brauchen, ich würd ja da meinen Website-Crawler drauf
machen. Strato ist eine Katastrophe. Also, ich find, äh, gut, die müssen halt billig
sein, ne, sonst. Ne, das ist nicht nur für die ersten drei Monate, das ist, das ist
konstant. Kriegt man ne Public-IP? Und, ach ja, das nächste ist, kann man zusätzliche
IPs mieten? Kann man zusätzliche IPs mieten? Das müsste man jetzt auch noch. Ist da ne
Public-IP dabei? Eigene IP, ja? Aber das ist ultra billig, das kann, das kann, da muss
ne Haken sein. Da muss ne Haken dran sein. Es gibt hier keiner, nen halbwegs performanten
1G-Server. Wie siehts mit Traffic aus? All-Inclusive-Traffic. Das stimmt fast nicht. Das sind China-Server
oder so. Die würden massiv drauf zahlen. Ich mein, guck mal was, das ist ne Hausnummer.
10 Kerne, 48G-Ramen. Dieser Arbeitsfall steht ihren Anwalt jederzeit zur Verfügung. Ne,
das ist mit SSH-Access, was die da, was auch immer die da für ne komisches, was juckt
mich, was die für nen Config-Panel haben. Das muss ich ja net verwenden. Achso, das
ist der, was denn das für, das kennst du nicht mehr? KVM? Achso. Ach, das ist so nen,
das ist quasi sowas wie OpenVZ oder sowas in der Richtung. Gibt, warum gibt's das überhaupt
noch? Ich dachte, das ist seit Linux-Container-Mainstream ist voll gestorben. Ja, ok, das sackt, das
sackt. Wir probieren das trotzdem mal aus. Wir probieren das trotzdem mal aus und ich
mach den dann mal, ernsthaft, ich mach den dann einfach mal 2 Stunden alle 10 Kerne dicht
und RAM voll. Mal gucken, mal gucken, wann der Server abgeschaltet wird. Die Einschränkung,
die Einschränkung ist, dass das anscheinend nicht voll virtualisiert ist. Also das heißt,
wenn du nen anderen Kernel oder Kernel-Module oder irgendwas laden willst, geht das schon
mal nicht. Das ist das erste, was mir so pauschal einfällt. VPNs wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht
richtig funktionieren. Docker wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren, ja, richtig, das könnten
wir mal ausprobieren. Äh, übrigens, 1&1 hat mich früher mal gekündigt, weil sich
es nicht gelohnt hat. Die hatten ja... 1&1 hatte ich mal DSL und die haben mich nicht
gekündigt, die haben mir den Brief geschrieben, so nach dem Motto, das stand da wortwörtlich
drin, seien wir mal ehrlich, das lohnt sich nicht. Das ist schon aber ewig, ja 15 Jahre
oder so, mindestens. Ganz, ganz lange her, DSL 1&1. Und die haben mir 100 Euro geboten,
wenn ich den Vertrag auflöse. Tja. Ich hab das dann auch gemacht und ich bin zu Alice,
falls jemand auch Alice als Provider kennt. Das war Hansenet, dann war es Alice und jetzt
weiß ich nicht, was es geworden ist. Ok, das ist tatsächlich der Haken, weil ansonsten
ohne Scheißleute ist das ab, also wenn das eine richtig echte VM wäre. Ach, O2 ist das,
ja. Wäre das echt richtig billig. 22 Euro, 10 Kerne, 48 Gb, fast 1TB SSD. Ne. Gibt's,
die Sache ist, es gibt Zusatz-IPs, Cluster-IP, optional. Weil ich brauch 10 extra IPs, sonst
gilt's nicht. Probieren wir in einem der nächsten Streams aus, easy. So, ich muss Chat weiterlesen.
Ja, so sieht's aus. Gibt es eigentlich noch deine dubiosen, ja die gibt's noch, die gibt's
noch. Allerdings, die haben sich komplett transformiert, also sprich, der Provider, wo
ich meine Ausbildung gemacht hab, das hab ich ja im letzten Video gesagt, das war, als
ich angefangen hab, so richtig nicer Technikladen. Die Leute waren zwar ein bisschen komisch,
aber technisch hatten die Ahnung. Und heute ist das so ein komplett, komplett seelenloser
Business-Stonks-Sachen, die beispielsweise Vertragsdinger für die Telekom machen und
sowas. Also, total, nichts sagen eigentlich. Die Erde ist in einer Eierjahrform, ja ich
wusste, ich wusste schon immer. Ihr habt es zuerst gehört, Leute. Das Setting ist mir
egal oder zumindest nicht so wichtig. Es muss halt was taugen. Ich werd's mir nicht pre-ordern.
Welche Heizungssteuerung? Ja, genau, das ist der richtige Stream, korrekt.
Webkastenbau, Webseitenbaukasten, ja. Es gab mal Zeiten, da hat jeder von uns mal
so einen Webseitenbaukasten zusammengeklickt. Heute nehmen die Leute aber dafür, ah fuck,
wie hieß das? Wix.com nehmen die Leute doch heute für Webseitenbaukasten. Oder? Wix.com.
Wix ist out, okay. Entwickler, die nur Wordpress können, sowas haben wir bei uns auf der Arbeit
auch. Wisst ihr, was mir da immer auffällt? Die Leute, die am wenigsten Ahnung haben,
die machen oftmals auf am meisten dicke Hose, dass man sie nicht exposed. Ich hatte ja auch
letztens wieder einen, richtig geil. Warte mal, lass mal kurz überlegen, was der wollte.
Genau, der wollte in irgendeinem Konfigurationsmanagement Einträge haben. Da habe ich zu ihm gesagt,
ja, das können wir jetzt temporär machen, aber das muss unbedingt weg, weil das ist
schon nicht mehr supportete Version. Also in spätestens ein, zwei Monaten kommt das
eh weg, also das ziehen wir auf keinen Fall um. Wir können das jetzt erstmal temporär
machen und es passt. Er hat ein Ticket aufgemacht, wo drin stande. Ich brauche eine zweite Zeile
in der Konfig. Also die Konfig sah ungefähr so aus. Das war eine JSON-Konfig, also so nach
dem Motto bla, bla, bla, value und da stand dann drinnen irgendeine IP-Adresse und irgendeine
Uhr. So sah die Konfig ungefähr aus. Nee, der ist ungefähr so alt wie ich, also eigentlich
sollte der, der hätte da schon bessere Chancen gehabt. So sah das aus und er hatte ein Ticket
aufgemacht, wohlgemerkt, er ist Entwickler, Entwickler, aber wir haben eh ganz viel komische
Entwickler, wo ich mich immer frage, was entwickeln die eigentlich den ganzen Tag, so wenig Ahnung
wie die haben und er meinte, er hat ein Ticket bei mir aufgemacht und meinte, er braucht
eine zweite Zeile in der Konfig. Da habe ich gesagt, okay, wie genau darf man sich das
bei dieser Konfig vorstellen? Wie soll eine zweite Zeile aussehen? Und er meinte, ja,
eine zweite Zeile bei value. Da habe ich zu ihm gesagt, das ist ein key value pair. Das
ist normal, dass das ein key hat und einen value, mehr geht nicht. Meint er vielleicht,
dann habe ich ihn gefragt, meint er vielleicht, dass man den value zu einem Array macht und
noch was zweites reinschreibt? So, das habe ich ihm mehr oder weniger eins zu eins so gefragt,
so lag die Motto. Soll man den zu einem Array machen und ein zweites Element reinschreiben?
Und dann hat er mir geantwortet, er hat es absolut nicht gecheckt. Er hat es absolut
nicht gecheckt. Er hat mir dann geantwortet, ja, okay, dann erkläre ich es noch einmal
von vorne. Er hat quasi so gedacht, als hätte ich es nicht gecheckt. Dabei hatte er keinen
blassen Schimmer, was er haben wollte. Ja, dann erkläre ich es noch einmal von vorne.
Wenn ich diesen und diesen Befehl ausführe, dann kommt jetzt eine Zeile raus. Ich möchte
dass da zwei Zeilen rauskommen. Und dann hat er noch dabei geschrieben, und dann hat er
noch dabei geschrieben, sorry fürs verwirren. Sorry fürs verwirren, das war etwas zu kompliziert
geschrieben. Ich hatte danach natürlich immer noch keine Ahnung, was er haben will. Und
dann habe ich ihn nochmal gefragt, ja, also, ich ignoriere sowas mittlerweile. Und ich
habe ihn gefragt, ja, also soll ich value zu einem Array machen und das zweite reinschreiben?
Er hat mir da keine Antwort draufgegeben. Er hat schlicht und ergreifend nicht verstanden,
was ich von ihm will. Bis ich dann irgendwann gesagt habe, ich probiere das jetzt mal aus
und dann fragst du mal ab und guckst, ob es jetzt zwei Zeilen sind. Ey, Badalbums, das
ist unglaublich, wie viele Entwickler es gibt, die keinen Plan haben. Also, es gibt
genug Techniker, also es müssen nicht nur Entwickler sein, ja, alle möglichen, die
keinen Platz in Schimmer haben. Es ist echt sehr merkwürdig. Und vor allem das geile
ist, dass er auch wieder so getan hat, als hätte ich das nicht verstanden. Dabei hat
er sich absolut unkonkret geäußert. Ja, wie gesagt, zu teuer. Ja, habe ich ja schon
beantwortet. Wir probieren das mit Strato aus im nächsten Stream. Ich mache das jetzt
nicht. Ich mache den Volllast auf 10 Kern und macht 48G RAM voll. Kein Problem. Einfach
gucken, ob es das geht. Ja, das hatten wir schon. Ne, das schreiben die nie hin. Bei
Hetzner sind es unten drunter AMD Epic Dinger. Habe ich auch nicht ausprobiert. Ich wollte
es mit OVH ja nur ausprobieren, weil ich so dicke Wärmung mit ihrer DDoS Protection
mache. Ja, gibt es genug. Jaja, das liegt am Raspberry Pi. Der Raspberry Pi sackt als
Nass. Der Raspberry Pi hat als Nass erstens für Krypto-Hardware zu schwache CPU und auch
Bandbreite, was USB und Netzwerk angeht, ist zwar schon besser, aber auch nicht der absolute
Wahnsinn. Aber die fehlenden Krypto-Extensions sind das Problem. Und die CPU ist auch ein
bisschen schwach. Gerade wenn du noch eine Raid machst oder so. Du bekommst das Gigabit
voll allerdings nur mit einer SSD dran und sag mal so, ohne jeglichen Sachen. Du SCPsst
oder du... weil selbst über den Samba wird es wahrscheinlich schon ein bisschen eng.
Guck dir mal Contabo an, kann ich machen. So. Übrigens ist unglaublich, wie viele Leute
nicht über IPv6 erreichbar sind. Ich habe mal einen Test gemacht, weil wie gesagt, ich
habe mir 10 extra IPs gekauft, dass ich besser Webseiten crawlen kann. Und ich dachte mir,
wenn die alle über IPv6 erreichbar sind, dann crawl ich einfach über IPv6, weil für
den Inhalt ist das egal und es kostet nix. Problem ist, erster Shop den ich geguckt habe,
PC King, kein IPv6.
Was der am Ende wollte, na wie gesagt, dass ich... also ich vermute mal, dass ich einen
Array draus mache. Er hat es mir bis zum Ende nicht gesagt. By the way, das Ticket, lustiger
Weise geht dabei. Das Ticket haben wir dann geschlossen, ohne dass ich es gemacht habe,
weil ich habe ihm gesagt, ich... Netcup habe ich mir gekannt, kann ich mir... guck ich
mir alles an, wir haben ja heute ein bisschen Zeit. Ich habe dann am Ende zu ihm gesagt,
ich mache da mal einen Array draus und guckst ob es funktioniert. Und dann habe ich das
gepusht und dann festgestellt, die Config wurde permanent wieder überschrieben, nachdem
ich die gepusht habe. Und in jedem Fall kam dann raus, irgendein Monitoring System pusht
den gleichen Key, den er von mir geändert haben wollte, in die Config rein. Ganz, ganz
schwere Sachen wieder. Und da haben wir das Ticket dann zugemacht und er ist zu den Leuten,
die dieses Monitoring System betreiben und lässt es jetzt von denen pushen, dass er seine
zwei Zeilen kriegt. Äh, das war ein Vollzeitentwickler, der ja schon ein paar Jahre dabei ist. Ich
glaube gar nicht, dass er so planlos ist, aber schwierig. Also in dem Bereich, wo er was
macht, wird er hoffentlich nicht so planlos sein. Aber wer heute so eine JSON-Config nicht
ordentlich erklären kann als Entwickler, stimmt schon, ist eigentlich auch Fail. Und weißt
es noch? Aha. Gleich bin ich mit dem Chat unten. Nice. Äh, einfach wohin gehen, wo man
sich nicht mit Kunden auseinandersetzen muss. Du bist wahrscheinlich im Support. Ich sag
dir jetzt mal, wie es ist. Endkunden-Support ist der größte Scheiß, den es gibt. So und
deswegen macht man sowas auch nicht. Also, kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Excellent, ich hab den Chat aufgeholt. Easy. Ok, können wir gucken. Leute, wisst ihr was
von allen Hostern? Ich bin mittlerweile mit Hetzner echt, echt, äh, bisher jetzt so insgesamt
am besten gefahren, ja. Das, wie gesagt, das ziemlich weg-Dedossen-Konten ist das eine,
aber da kann ja Hetzner auch nur am Rande was für. Zweifelsfall drück ich einfach
bei Cloudflare auf Attack Mode. Also meine Lieblings-Support-Anfrage, auf die ich zu
doof war zu antworten, das hat sich mal in so einem Sammelpostfach eine E-Mail verirrt
von jemand komplett außerhalb des Hauses, der aber wohl ein bisschen was mit uns zu
tun hatte. Irgendwas, was wir sponsoren oder so, irgendein Verein oder ach, keine Ahnung,
ja, also, ganz woanders. Und die ist bei uns im E-Mail-Postfach gelandet und ich hab mir
gedacht, ok, anstatt das zu ignorieren, bist du mal nett und antwortest ihr, dass sie
hier komplett falsch ist und, ähm, wenn sie mir sagt, um was für ein System es geht,
dann kann ich ihr vielleicht sagen, wer der richtige Ansprechpartner ist. Und dann hat
sie ganz, ganz empört geantwortet, na selbstverständlich geht es um das System, mit dem wir täglich
arbeiten. So hab ich dann geguckt. Hab ich gedacht, aha, ok, CU. Also, gut, dann helf
ich dir halt nett, ja, Pech gehabt. Also, zeig mal her, was haben die denn? Nett Kupp.
Haben die auch so geile DDoS-Protection wie OVH? OVH war der einzige Grund, warum ich
die angeguckt hab, wegen Poggers DDoS-Protection. Aber, wie gesagt, die kommen auch mit Hetzer
und Cloudflare da vor, klar. Also, was haben die denn hier? Root-Server, Rubi-Server,
ne. Wir fangen jetzt nicht an damit, Leute. So, ähm, zeig mal her, was haben die denn
für VMS? Ich hab mal eine, oh, das ist eine lange Frage. Muss mal kurz durch den, also
der Loki fragt, ich hab mal eine Frage, du bist leider der Einzige, den ich verfolge,
das beantworten kann. Ja, das mittigste Beantworten muss erst mal Primes haben. Was sollte ich
denn beachten, wenn ich ein paar Sachen, hauptsächlich alte Sport-Tokos und ein paar alte Champions
League-Spiele von Uploaden, was von Uploaden downloaden will? Ja, das kannst du machen.
Aber kein, ne, genau, nehmt keinen Torrent, aber wenn du das so vorhast, ist das eigentlich
kein Problem, ja. Die sind in der Regel auch nicht hinter Downloadern her, sondern hinter
Uploaden. Und, ähm, wenn du das über deinen VPN machst, klar, wenn du dich aufpasst, kann
man das trotzdem nachvollziehen und je nachdem, was dein VPN-Anbieter macht, aber ich denke,
du hast da nicht allzu viel zu befürchten.
Echt? In welchem LZ ist Hetzer? Achso, das ist ja nicht in Frankfurt, die sind ja in Nuremberg
und Faltenburg, ne. Genau, also wie gesagt, bloß keinen Torrent nehmen. Torrent ist das
Ding Nummer eins, wo die Leute beim Uploaden erwischt werden. OVH ist in Frankfurt, da
bin ich bestimmt schon mal vorbeigelaufen. Also, an denen im Rack oder an den Racks,
könntest du mir vorstellen. Ich war ja schon in ein paar RZs in Frankfurt. Exellent. Na,
Torproxy bringt dir für Downloads nichts, das ist zu langsam. War jetzt nicht ernst
gemeint, aber trotzdem, Dankeschön für die Subscription. Genau, in Helsinki. Der Krümel
giftet an Blue Media. Nice, Dankeschön für den Gift. Huge Subscriptions, Leute. IQ++.
Es gibt ein paar modifizierte Torrent-Klines, aber ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich habe
Torrents seit Jahren nicht mehr benutzt und verfolge das Null, was es da gibt. Ich kaufe
mir mittlerweile eh zum größten Teil alles, das einzige, was ich mir noch lade, sind Sachen,
wo die Hersteller halt irgendwie das nicht releasen wollen oder in scheiß Settings,
scheiß Sprache, was auch immer, nur releasen. Dann gucke ich mir das in irgendeinem Stream
an. Ich downloade es noch nicht, ich gucke mir das meistens in irgendeinem Stream an.
Ja, mach ich, mach ich. Den müsste ich mal zurückrufen, war jetzt ein bisschen spät.
Er muss halt nur gucken, dass man nichts liegt. War GameStop? Ja, aber schon. Also genau,
jetzt wollte ich mal kurz gucken, was haben die 16 Cores, 12 Cores, 12 Cores ist genau
richtig für den Crawler. Guck mal, die haben, das ist aber auch günstig. 12 Cores, 12 Cores
für 30. Bei Hetzner bezahlste für den 8-Core, glaube 25 oder so, 27. Da kann mein Crawler
noch besser Crawlen, Alter. 80G Traffic reicht für den Crawler? Reicht das? Welcher VPN
ist am besten? Keine Ahnung, kenne ich mich nicht mit aus. Macht aber wahrscheinlich alles
keinen großen Unterschied. FalscherHase390, Dankeschön für den PrimesUp. Wieso 80T ist
vollkommen in Ordnung? 80T ist vollkommen okay. Bei Hetzner hast du 20, allerdings
sind die 20 nur outgoing, also sprich, die ganzen Anfragen nicht. Also bei Hetzner ist
es im Prinzip fast so was wie Unlimited. Du hast was geupdatet. Nice. Du kannst dir,
also entweder schickst du die im Discord alle, dem Sie baro oder ziehst sie in Emotes, Chat,
ich gucke mir die dann morgen früh an. Was könnte man da als Emote machen? Wuppsabba,
aber ein 12 Kerner, ein 12 Kerner für 30 finde ich gut. Also das ist, das ist zum Beispiel
jetzt eine ganze Ecke günstig. Kann man, haben die Zusatz-IPs Leute? Wisst ihr das
zufällig? Haben die Zusatz-IPs? Kann man da Zusatz-IPs bestellen? 1 Euro! Achso, das
sind 12, die haben geupdatet, genau, das sind 12 Monatspreise. Die geupbaten richtig, das
hatten wir doch schon mal. Die Seite kenne ich, da haben wir doch schon mal geguckt. Wenn
man das dann umstellt, wenn man das dann umstellt, dann ja 52 Euro. Direkt kündigbar.
Richtig jebaitet. Ich weiß, dass ich beim 12, beim 16 Core bin, aber ein 16 Core, ein
16 Core für 40 Euro Monat hätte ich halt auch genommen. Server, nimm richtig Server,
kann ich auch mal gucken. Wo haben die die denn stehen? Ach da. 2 Kerne, 4 Kerne, 6 Kerne,
10 Kerne. Ja, macht auch keinen großen Unterschied, ne? Die ersten 10 Kerne, 46 im Monat. Hä,
das ist auch KVM? Moment, das ist KVM und das ist KVM. Hab ich hier einfach mehr Reservierungen
auf KVM oder wie? Wahrscheinlich. Ach gut, da kann ich auch bei Hetzer bleiben. Wie gesagt,
ich hätte OVH eh nur genommen wegen der, wegen den eher angepriesenen DDoS Protection.
Warte mal, ist der Preis Champ so? Champ da noch? Ja, Champ noch alles. Ok, da sollt
ich jetzt auch nochmal gucken, habt ihr gesagt. German Quality, since 2003. Was hostest du
da drauf? Das hier hoste ich da drauf. Der Preis Champ. Der besteht aus, also man muss
da vielleicht mal erklären, warum das so viel Leistung braucht. Also, das ist ein Vue.js
Content mit einem ASP.NET Backend. Das braucht selbst bei 500 Benutzern, ich hatte vorhin
kurz 500 Benutzern, nachdem ich das Twitter gepostet hatte, gleichzeitig, braucht das
keine Ahnung, 4-5% CPU Leistung. Nix. Was CPU Leistung braucht, ist der Crawler, der
die Daten aktualisiert. Der braucht zu Spitzenzeiten 12 Cores auf meinem 16-Core-Server. Kim.com
geht auf Twitter ab. Macht der das? Warum macht der das? Zeig mal was, was macht der
denn? Warum hat der Typ plus 17,8? Achso, ah, ah, verguckt. Ich wollt grad sagen, der
hat doch nie im Leben plus 17,2 Follower. Äh, Car Follower. Was geht mit ihm denn jetzt
ab? Ok, ja und weiter. Deep State, das ist ja auch so das neueste Ding. Das hier würde
ich tatsächlich unterschreiben, ja. Was will er denn? Äh, ok. Ich hatte ja ehrlich gesagt
so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, dass Trump noch, bevor er abdankt, ein paar Leute begnadigt,
hat aber keinen Bock drauf gehabt. Kim.com hat ja noch Geld, wahrscheinlich hat er mehr
Geld als wir zusammen, ja. So, ähm, also was haben die denn hier am Start? Virtual Dedicated
Server für 32, für? Ah, nee, virtual, aber. Zehner? Ja, das ist, das ist genau so was,
was ich brauch von der Größe her. Traffic? Was sagt der Traffic? Übrigens, ich hab immer
noch mein Lifetime kostenlos, mein Lifetime kostenlos VM Server. Ich hatte mir mal, ich
hatte mir ja mal vor acht Jahren, hab ich mal ein Log-Angebot gefunden von einem Cloud-Anbieter,
von einem Dota-Hoster damals, der gesagt hat, bezahl einmalig 35 Euro und bekomm eine VM
mit fester IPv4-Adresse auf Lebenszeit. Hab ich gemacht. Allerdings ist das der wirklich,
jetzt ohne Scheiß, der schlechteste und beschissenste Hoster, den es gibt. Warte mal, mal gucken,
ob es die überhaupt noch gibt. Ich verwende die Kiste nicht mehr. Ja. Oh, die haben upgradet.
Sieht jetzt besser aus. Sieht jetzt, sieht jetzt besser aus. Aber ohne Scheiß, der ist
so schlecht. Der ist so dermaßen schlecht. Warum sind die auf einmal jetzt teuer geworden?
Okay, die sind von, die sind von Billig Crap-Anbieter zu, wir sind teuer und, und machen es vielleicht
gescheit, gegangen, keine Ahnung. Ah ja, ah ja. One-Time-Payment. Ah ja, kann man mal
machen, oder? Also, die sind mehr down als up. Richtiger Crap. Die machen immer noch
so One-Time-Dinger. Die wollen mir nur nicht wirklich erzählen. Die geben mir für 69 Euro
auf Lebenszeiten Terabyte-Speicher. Das ist genauso Scam-Mast, wie mit dem anderen Server,
den ich da bei denen bestellt habe. Die haben da nämlich richtig gescampt nach einer Zeit
und haben gesagt, ey, wir möchten jetzt eine, eine Wartungs-Fee haben, damit wir den Server
umziehen können, weil irgendwie ist das kaputt und damit wir den Server weiter betreiben
können für sie, wollen wir irgendwie 10 Euro für die Wartung haben und so. Da wollten
sie mich debaten. Einfach Alibaba klaut, ja. Aber das hier finde ich eigentlich ein ganz
gutes Angebot. Das testen wir auch mal. Das testen wir im nächsten Stream. Im nächsten,
die Magenta klaut er lustigerweise keine VMs zu bieten. So, das finde ich von Einrichtungsgebühr,
Alter. Einrichtungsgebühr. Wollt ihr mich verarschen? Also, okay, die labern wenigstens
nicht viel von klaut. Also, die haben mich ja echt ein bisschen enttäuscht, ne? Das
OVH klaut, bla, bla, bla. Und das erste, was du liest, ist 48 Stunden zur Einrichtung.
Das ist nicht das, was ich mir unter klaut vorstelle, ehrlich gesagt. Aber das hier
finde ich echt ein ganz gutes Angebot. Kennt den Anbieter jemand? Ich brauche da kein
High-Traffic-Gedöns. Ich will da meinen Crawler drauf laufen lassen, der einfach nur Rechenleistung
braucht. Und wichtig ist Zusatz-IPs. Gibt es Zusatz-IPs? Ich brauche Zusatz-IPs. Einrichtung,
reguläre Setup. Was ist das denn wieder? Sie möchten nicht lange auf ihre neuen Server
warten. Alter, bauen die den noch ein oder was? Warum, ich frage mich warum Hetzner hier
so von diesen normalen Hostern hier in Deutschland. Der einzige ist, der irgendwie das Wort klaut
noch halbwegs ernst nimmt. Du klickst auf den Knopf und 15 Sekunden später ist das
Ding da. Ich will nicht einen halben Tag warten, bis eine VM da ist. Ja, netcup mag sein, aber
ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wo der Vorteil davon wäre. Die kosten ungefähr genauso viel,
aber ja kann sein, habe ich nicht ausprobiert. Okay. Gibt es Zusatz-IP? Ja, eine IP inklusive.
Wow. Die wollen 3 Euro pro IP, das heißt ich bezahle 30 Euro nochmal obendrauf für
die IPs, bei Hetzner bezahle ich 11 Euro. Can't wait. Sonst für den Crawler, nee passt,
das ist vollkommen in Ordnung. 8K bei Hetzner ist preisleistungsmäßig top für den Crawler.
Kann ich downcranen vom 16-Core, sobald ich halt fürs Frontend einen 4-Kerner irgendwo
gemietet habe. Aber ansonsten finde ich das Preis leistungsmäßig echt in Ordnung. 26,99,
10 Kerne, 60, sag mal was, sag mal scheißen die alle RAM? Nee Digital Ocean ist zu teuer,
bei denen war ich auch schon öfters mal für Kleinkram. Bei Digital Ocean hatte ich mir
für Open Street Maps das Zeug geholt mit 690G RAM und 48 Kernen und so, bis ich dann irgendwann
damit auch zu Hetzner bin. Alpha Hosting, das heißt nicht wirklich so oder? Das heißt
wirklich so. Alpha Hosting, da macht er schon den Alpha Move, ich sehe es. Ok, ok, wo sind
die VMs? Guck mal, die haben nur Pro und Premium. Pro, Premium, Pro, Premium. Dedicated, Pro,
Dedicated, Premium, ok. Laufzeit wählen, 1 Monat Lauf. Alter, Alpha Preise haben sie
nicht. Ah, 5 Sterne, yeah. Und wo? Bei Google. Haben die keine VMs? Alter. Ah, hier Cloud
AWS, da sind die VMs. Bis zu 12 Cores, das ist auch in Ordnung, das ist auch in Ordnung.
12 Cores, 25 Euro, SSD Turbo, RAM. Was? Was? 120 MBit? Wollte ich mich veräppeln? Damit
kriege ich ja nimmer 2 Seiten gleichzeitig gecrawled, Alter. Naja gut, keine 3 Seiten
gleichzeitig gecrawled. Ich bin, ich komme hier wieder zurück, Hetzner ist preisleistungsmäßig
einfach echt top, da kann man nix sagen. Das sind mega Bit, nicht MB. Was geht jetzt
los? Es ist ja absolut unübersichtlich, wieviel Hosting Geschichten es gibt. Traffic,
ja gut, bei 120 MBit kann ich auch, kann ich, garantierte. 50, das habe ich permanent.
Okay, ich zeige euch mal, wieviel Bandbreite ich brauche. Und ich habe schon, ich habe
schon den Low Bandbreiten Modus, ne? Ich habe schon den Low Bandbreiten Modus an. Steht
da irgendwo die Bandbreite? Habt ihr irgendwo die Bandbreite gesehen? Traffic, Traffic,
die Packets? Ah, Network Traffic Basic. Naja gut, doch, ich würde damit hinkommen. Aber
ich habe, ich habe auch den Low Bandbreiten Modus an. Also 7 MBit oder so brauche ich
denke ich mal. Zwischenzeit schon mal ein bisschen mehr. Ja, aber trotzdem 120 MBit,
was ist denn das? Wo hast du deinen, du meinst bei Porkbun, das ist auch irgendwie so ein
billig Crap-Anbieter, den ich mal nur ordentlich DNS-API habe, deswegen habe ich immer eine
Nameserver bei Cloudflare. Genau, das läuft über einen VDSL von dem, vom Alpha, vom
Alpha, Alter. Wieso nicht zur AWS, weil AWS fucking teuer ist für VMs. Und du bei AWS
jeden Furz extra bezahlst. Also Preis-Leistungs-mäßig ist Hetzner wirklich das Beste bisher. Netcap
kann ich nicht sagen, hatte ich noch nichts zu, aber von der Flexibilität her, von den
Bonussachen, die man mieten kann und Preis-Leistung ist Hetzner echt super. So ein OVH muss halt
wohl echt gute DDoS-Protection haben und ein bisschen teurer sein. Ich muss mich nicht
bei Hetzner leaken, sondern bei OVH. Hetzner habe ich meine, nicht meine echte Adresse
eingetragen. Ich mache das ja nur, damit ich mich nicht leaken muss, also nicht leaken
kann, wenn ich mal im Stream auf die Profilseite klicke aus Versehen. Wenn jetzt irgendeiner
neu in den Stream kommt, denkt er sich auch was passieren hier für unethische Dinger
im Stream. Ja, die glauben mir nicht, dass man Peter Wobbel heißt. Macht das doch voll,
man kriegt es leider nicht größer. Und jetzt die Maus noch weg, und jetzt die Maus noch
weg. Das einzige, was man im Stream sieht, ist jetzt das da. Nee, die Gifts habe ich
doch nicht drinne. Yes. Tja. Leute, ich fürchte ja, es ist jetzt
22.10 Uhr. Ich fürchte ja, ich gehe jetzt off. Was macht eigentlich der Frazier? Dammit
on. Elton, danke schön für den Sub. Excellent IQ++ Subscription. Das war schon immer so,
wo ich jünger war. Nur wer ordentlich schläft, kann Big Brain Sachen vollbringen. Semper,
ist er auf Twitch? Wirklich? Moment, Moment, Moment. Der streamt doch nicht live. Das ist
ein Video, was der streamt, oder? Maus Zeiger. Das ist einfach ein Video, was der hochlädt.
Der lädt die Videos hoch und es premiert gerade. Jaja, guck mal, der lädt einfach nur. Moment,
bringt der das Video? Das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken. Was macht? Oh nee, der geht
danach. Und ja, hosten wir den jetzt. Danke, wir hosten den jetzt. Einfach mal nice oder
raiden den. Raiden wir noch mal. Exquisite. Also Leute, könnt ihr am anderen Runde Wupp
gassen mit Spam in Chat? Also Leute, wir sehen uns, machts gut, bis morgen oder so, bis dann.